الى الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد
الياس حنا مرحبا بك سيد العميد
ما هي المصاعب او المتاعب التي يواجهها
الطرفان لحسم معركه باخموت الان اشهر
والحديث عن ذلك هناك حاله استعصاء
يواجهها طرفان
عبد الصمد اولا عدم الجهوزيه التكتيكيه
والعسكريه ان كان في العديد او العتاد من
الجهه الروسيه يعني هناك في مخلوط من
يقاتل من
القوات الاساسيه وهناك خلاف بين الاثنين
اثنين كان لدى القوات الاوكرانيه الوقت
اللازم منذ العام 2014 لتدعيم هذه المنطقه
دفاعيا وهذا ما قاله
بريكوجين عندما قال وراء كل بيت هناك قلعه
ولا كل قلعه هناك خط دفاع فاذا نحن امام
مرحله لا يمكن حتى الان وقد تنسحب
اوكرانيا الانسحاب من مخلوط لعدم اعطاء
الرئيس بوتين انتصارا بمناسبه الذكرى
الاولى للحرب وذلك بانتظار ايضا الجهوزيه
للمرحله القادمه
بالنسبه لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه التي
سوى له الان دول اوروبيه على راسها
بريطانيا هل تعتقد بان هذا التدريب او
الوقت المخصص للتدريب والاعداد التي يتم
تدريبها من بالاوكراني قادره على تغيير
الموازين بالنظر ايضا الى الخلل في موازين
القوه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
عبد الصمد العدد دائما هو للجيش الروسي
وهناك نقاط ايجابيه مهمه لصالح الروسي انه
يقاتل على حدوده المشتركه انه يتكل على
نفسه الى حد ما بينما اوكرانيا
الاستراتيجيه والنجاح يتكل على دعم الغرب
المستمر هناك تدريب اساسي مهم خاصه منذ
يومين انتهى ما يقارب لواء 635 جندي
اوكرانيا تدربوا في المانيا على يد الجيش
الامريكي يبقى عبد الصمد كيف يمكن دمج هذا
العسكر مع الاسلحه الجديده ادخالها الى
اوكرانيا وبالتالي الجهوزيه قبل ان يبدا
الرئيس بوتين بما يسمى هجوم ما بعد الشتاء
هل الطرفان عاجزه فعلا على حسم ام ان هناك
رغبه ربما غربيه او
انشينا نقول غير معلنه ان يطول امد هذه
الحرب وهذه المواجهه لان كل ما طاله امدها
كلما ضعف ربما وفق الرؤيه الغربيه
الجانب الروسي الى اي حد هذه القراءه ربما
واقعيه
من يستطيع ان يربح من يستطيع ان يربح لا
يؤجل الامر اليوم هناك عجز في تحرير كل
اوكرانيا كما عجز من جهه الجيش الروسي ان
يسيطر على كل اوكرانيا اليوم نحن في مرحله
الحسم للوصول الى درجه يقتنع فيها كل
الافرقه انه لا بد من الجلوس الى الطاوله
حتى الان هذا الامر ليس متوفرا وليس جاهزا
حتى الان فاذا المرحله ليست مرحله هي
مرحله استنزاف بالطبع ولكن اليوم ما يريده
الروسي لا يملك وسائل خاصه به تكفي وما
يريده الاوكراني لا يملك الوسائل هناك
عمليه تحديد الافضليات يعني تثبت في مكان
وتقاتل في مكان بانتظار تحول جزري على
صعيد المعركه او ساحه المعركه على ذكر
امكانيات الاوكرانيه كما قلت سيد عميد هل
الغرب مستعد ان يقدم المزيد على مدى طويل
لاوكرانيا هل مستعد ان يذهب بعيدا في هذا
الدعم حتى وان كان ربما في غير صالحه او
على حساب
يعني
قدراته الاقتصاديه
اليوم عبد الصمد الموضوع جيو سياسي بعيد
عن الاختصاد اذا ربح الروسي سيكون على
حدود النيتو اليوم كل الاجتماعات الغربيه
حتى اخرها في ميونخ يؤكد ان هناك
استمراريه معينه والحرب لم تعد بالمعنى
الاساسي وفي جوهرها هي بين اوكرانيا
مباشره وروسيه هي بين الغرب ككل بدعمنا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ضد الروسي
لاضعافه من ضمن المبدا عدم احراج الرئيس
بوتين بخساره مذله كي لا يذهب الى التصعيد
حتى النووي شكرا كالعميد ليصحنه الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت شكرا لك